[Music]
we don't talk anymore Charlie puth
finally revealing what happened with
Selena Gomez while they worked on their
duet we don't talk anymore
twenty-six-year-old covers the new issue
of billboard and when asked about the
CLAB says quote I don't kiss and tell
but the only way a song like that can
come across as real as if there's
something else going on behind the
scenes he says that's what was happening
with Selena calling it quote very
short-lived very small but very
impactful and it really messed me up he
admits art imitated lace a Dean I'm
trying to put this the best way possible
it wasn't like I was the only person on
her mind and I think I knew that going
in still there's no hard feelings
calling it a pleasure to work with her
in October Charlie played coy on Selena
to ET she's a good girl and she's a
great singer people sleep on her voice
she's a great thing no she's a good
singer I'm a good singer Selena is now
back with Justin Bieber they were
snapped leaving a hockey rink in Los
Angeles on Wednesday